se você conhece o deserto do carai água
limpa aí direto da fonte fria quantidade
de vida que existe por lá ok isso é um
ovo outro lugar surpreendente com uma
pessoa completamente desconhecida por
isso é invisível que tem o pode estar ao
seu lado essa planta tem humildade que
tem que o meu deus eu não acredito que
vem aqui me acostumo eu quero ir para
casa primeiro elefantes não tem nada
disso anal porém chuva em dura e muita
conversa
tô bem só não vai ter que ter que
explicar que até quais são os seus
vídeos não sabemos nosso deus história
vamos nos termos a morte lascados e
pelados versão brasileira não te
interessa planeta terra brasil com é
assim por favor em localizado no
interior do piauí o deserto do carai é
uma maravilha da natureza ainda
desconhecida pelo homem suas belezas
escondem o windows mistérios é aqui por
exemplo que a onça bebe água sem
canudinho durante 259 dias 17:48
minutinhos os participantes terão a
difícil missão de desvendar vários
perigos do jeito que vieram ao mundo
conheça brian stevens meu nome é brian
bom dia eu vi de massa chuva seu raio eu
espero ficar mais que um dia por aqui eu
eu sou a pessoa certa para estar aqui
porque eu sempre amei a selva desde
criança eu subia nos pés de goiaba e
tirava goiabas em alta sabe e eu me
adapto bem altas temperaturas é como
você pode ver hoje é esquiei no maranhão
eu até saí com algumas escoriações mas
tudo bem
o ítalo
se você está um pouco tímido hoje não é
amiguinho só coloco isso aqui ó
e ai conheça também kimberlly johns uma
moça sem papas na língua de lacraia e
bia o meu nome é que bellinzoni vinham
vindo e haviam me convidaram para eu te
programa e eu aceito desafio meu amor
porque se eu estou aqui não importa o
quão difícil e o terça eu vou querer até
estou derretendo o carro eu tenho os
meus peitos não viu ê
boa tarde é louco olha eu sou meio
tímida
a pizza aqui ó
e ai olá e aí parceiro como papelada e
você eu não vejo que muita gente esse é
o teu pinto você é bem engraçada né eu
também eu falei esse jogo tá muito
pingando é o seu nome mesmo o meu nome é
brian o meu leque em berlim prazer
prazer te conhecer que eu acho que o
essencial para a vida é a água ora ora
temos um xeroque rolmes por aqui né meu
amor a pergunta é como vamos encontrar
eu não faço ideia mas eu não sei se
conseguiríamos sair daqui caminhando e o
teu deve porque isso em o chinelo a é
meio e olha eu não sei o que fazer aqui
é muito seco aí vamos apostar quem
perder vai no
e a coisas para fazer um chinelo que
acha levar até razoável batendo então
vamos lá ganhou não tem 25 era
brincadeira parceiro pelo amor de
interior seria um entendeu eu sou seu
amigo dele então eu pãozinho com
manteiga eu ganhei e eu vou
um ok eu vou lá
e é isso aí trabalho em equipe ele é
muito bonito ó
o amor pega fogo olha ai meu deus dragão
que você está vendo a jogar pelo calor
ea distância e vocês sabem pelo sol eu
só consigo ver uma coisa daqui o que a
morte vamos lá no programa que você
começar você só pensa em mim eu não vejo
possibilidade de vida daqui acredita que
você tá chorando vamos lá não foi essa
pessoa que eu conheci quando a gente se
encontrou no vai dar tudo certo e o que
eu não vou conseguir eu não tenho vale a
pena claro que vale a pena você sabe o
que acontece se a gente consegue ganhar
de graça entramos nas festas de graça
você quer entrar nas festas de graça
também vai ter um que eu quero entrar
nas festas de graça meu amor eu gosto o
meu nome é que belo horizonte
e você tá vendo alguma coisa eu não
venha do nada sabendo logo eu acho que
vamos ter que caminhar um pouco vou ter
que pariu brian nós não conseguimos você
errado tô mudando caminhar a gente vai
morrer vai morrer eu não respeito
e até que eu achei a gente bem positivo
sabe é muito estranho o fato de você
estar pelado em cima de uma árvore tem
uma pessoa embaixo ela pode ver o seu
ano sim isso é realmente muito estranho
sabe
a reflexão do bem eu não lembro de nunca
ter ficado pelada em cima de uma árvore
nem tem ninguém baixo sabe
e você tá rindo do meu pênis e eu acho
que estamos nos vendo tudo que é bem
sabe é ele é uma lombra é uma pessoa do
bem e daí lá eu sei que nós vamos morrer
de fome daqui alguns dias mas eu não tô
nem aí parceiro aqui é o piauí tudo pode
acontecer é uma lombra a sensação que
você tende a ficar pelado é
e é como se você se sentisse livre sabe
eu me sinto meio conectado e eu não sei
se se é dos meus antepassados ou ou de
alguma coisa que aconteceu com ali eu
sou naturista eu sou hipster eu sinto
que tenho que viver experiências novas e
eu não me importo de estar pelado aqui
em lugar algum tá ligado o meu anel tem
um pouco gelado fiquei até tempo
encobrindo ele é que eu sempre fico
assim até quando eu tô de roupa eu
sempre fico nessa posição eu gosto de
você tanto assim porque eu mandei para
assim um costume né que eles sempre
ficam a pregando na perna então é melhor
para eu ajeitar não tem nada a ver com o
tamanho sabe nem tudo é porque ele é
pequena e vocês só falam disso você você
não fala sobre mais nada aí só sobre
como eles são pequenos ricky e é só isso
é só que não para de falar dos
e aí faz alguma coisa de útil que eu vou
procurar água ou tem lá comida nem tudo
é sobre o nosso corpo eu passei não
estamos na terra para se não fizermos
alguma razão é realmente a gente precisa
fazer alguma mas eu vi bosta de vaca por
aqui então se tem bosta de vaca pode ter
vaca se tem vaga pode ter muitas vacas
muitas vacas mesmo que estamos mesmo do
brasil meu deus a gente tá na índia eles
não nos levariam para tão longe até
brian é verdade eu não faço ideia por
onde começar eu não tem nada para fazer
aqui a não ter
a julgar kkk é verdade eu não sei mas eu
acho que você vai desistir muito rápido
eu acho que meu maior desafio vai ter
ficar na companhia de um hetero vou
desligar sobre a [ __ ] cara eu hein e
sentido porque eu sou é tão bom
e vai ter o li na sua ficha de inscrição
ah tá porque eu não tinha te contado eu
achei estranho é que eu não tinha te
contado como você saberia entendi eu
tinha que questionar eu mandei é muito
estranho e qual é o teu problema cara
não tem problema nenhum oi isso é um
jogo a gente tem que prestar atenção em
tudo ou você acha que aqui é uma
brincadeira a gente não tem objetivo é
só andar e e sofrer e procurar meu deus
não importa brian se você não tem água
você morre [ __ ] mundo vai conseguir
isso você entende isso tu é doido ou se
faz parceiro você você se acha essa
[ __ ] eu acho que em determinado
momento do programa ela se alterou e
começou a ficar muito imperativa sabe
que é uma mistura de imperativo com o
imperador imperativa
e eu acho que eu pisei num tô leite de
vaca eu pisei eu fiz em outro leite de
vaca eu pisei no leite de vaca deus eu
tenho que sair daqui você pisou em um
toletão é isso que você merece bater
avisarem rio do lenço até porque você
não faz nada não serve nem para pega a
água então assim coletiva dele então ele
tentou letra para você terra de
coletinho você não me acerta grávida né
assim que até tem cidade youtuber bem
sabem mas brigamos no primeiro dia e é
normal e natural de cada ser humano tem
essa guerra e colocou no primeiro dia e
o programa está só começando então
porque se irrita não é mesmo parceira
tudo pode acontecer
e ai meu deus que planta é essa que tem
que encontrar outro então é muito fofo
onde é que pariu um
e a gente vai morrer eu concordo com
você fica com a minha animais por aqui
não tem possibilidades e tem animais por
aqui em cara eu via discovery channel
que nem fruta sabe
a [ __ ] que pariu não tem cupim como
assim não tem cupim tudo tempo brincar
ai meu deus eu não acredito e como assim
não tem coorpin eu quero ir para casa
para eu não aguento mais nada sobrevive
por aqui e eu acho que o mesmo vai
acontecer com a gente
um grave lugar repete vou para viajar
e vai pergunta que eu ia carinho eu
tenho vontade de história tá passando
todo um filme na minha cabeça tá
e aí
e ai meu deus oh mateus obrigado meu
deus se tem planta tem água é verdade eu
li isso no livro de ciências é ontem não
sei que tem água por perto eu só não
começa a planta com medo de ela ser
venenosa sabe o meu deus por que você
fez isso é
e está úmida é duplo então deve ter algo
por aqui vamos procurar agora vamos
procurar eu acho que isso é muito perto
vamos continuar procurando sabe o meu
deus eu acho que tem água em jericó
razão meu deus eu acho que contribuiu
com esses pontinhos ali só pode ser água
vou correr alguma coisa mais do pai ele
vai comprar logo o meu deus brian praia
e não não é
e agora eu sabia mano eu também ele ia
morrer eu sabia desde o começo sabia
hahaha [ __ ] que pariu um
a minha vida virou um inferno com esse
gato ele destruiu meu casamento a minha
casa aí ai meu deus olha só ele tá assim
desde que descobriu que dá para pedir
tudo na rap eu sempre peço compras de
supermercado na rápido e agora ele pede
ração para ele também ó meu deus acho
que vou pedir para rápido trazer outra
de mim pois eu mesmo não vou aguentar
e esse gato é muito folgado eu nunca vi
na minha vida toda um felino tão cretino
que passa o dia tocando cpm engenheiros
do hawaii não não é por
e canta uma música como tá os inimigos
ele parece ser a encarnação de satanás
mas fazer alguém moni teria vergonha
perto do que esse gato é capaz de fazer
você solte o que você está fazendo isso
deus vai me ajudar caso você vai
treinador maguili é com você não não faz
isso por favor
a [ __ ] que o pariu pare de me fazer
cobranças você também eu segurei ele na
sala para te esperar ele saiu e agora
ele está no banheiro ela vai lá banheiro
não pode ser caramba um cágado no chão
da cozinha aí ele mia para vizinha me
ver fazer isso é vergonhoso porque ele
não sai do banheiro e não me deixa
entrar então fica tudo aqui no chão você
vai conferir eu não estou acreditando
fezes ou na pessoa chega no ponto de
cagar no chão da própria casa é porque a
situação está desesperadora por favor me
pixando como esse tem que mostrar quem
manda mostrar confiança e isso aí tem um
cheiro do medo
o pai daquele gato e volta indisciplina
esse daqui é o maior desafio da minha
carreira mas nada é o bastante para o
treinador marquinhos
[Música]
oi meu gato desgraçado voltamos a
apresentar lascados e pelados
e onde está você você dor
e eu quero água eu preciso beber eu
quero voltar para mas a chuva para serem
para vocês nos inspirem vocês você não
vai acreditar o que eu achei água que
encima eu achei água aí eu fui pagar lá
longe e eu achei raiva ponto aqui para
aí eu falei de graça gente encontra água
sem por aí vai chover precisamos
terminar a [ __ ] da barraca vem por esse
lado aí viu que eu deixo eu vou ficando
aí me ajuda aí me dá um salve aqui na
terra pega a [ __ ] que
o pão de pizza notariais do youtube era
mais tarde cuidado para não esbarrar e
derruba tudo estamos longe a gente vai
conseguir consulta ao tento vai nós
damos conta da carreira então vamos
parar de falar e mãos à obra
e olha eu comprei que nós não é meu deus
e jesus meu deus ai meu deus meu deus
meu deus oh
o meu deus o que você pensa que a gente
está fazendo bem a gente não passa ver
se é doido e eu acho que eu fui peidar e
me caguei isso aí ontem para o seu merda
engraçada meu cérebro é fraco o meu é
muito forte eu tô meio corrido aqui eu
não consigo é
e agora assistindo eu sair da cabana
para mim já ou é melhor eu me já aqui
mesmo eu já que [ __ ] olha eu não
tenho mas eu não quero pegar
leptospirose né fosse tão desse lugar
aqui em cima né e hoje eu acho que eu tô
delirando sabe né
ah vai tomar no cu do que eles não tão
não vão eu não consigo segurar por lá e
certo na minha cara [ __ ] porque você
tem visto
g1
e eu tô usando o cara tem certeza que
não querem ou não eu acho muito mais
fácil sabe o internet o que você quer
brian eu quis dizer que é carolina e
pronto ok vamos o seu jeito dessa vez ok
vamos lá vamos lá então vamos lá então
vamos lá olha quer saber você pode
dormir onde você quiser o meu órgão
genital não é muito avantajado sabe ela
também você falando desse assunto de
novo 19 de novo meu deus é verdade ele
ficou bonita ficou pega no meu colega
ligou
a pipa eu ganhei então vocês olham de
dormir eu durmo na frente e eu durmo
mais crédito vamos lá lekão easylab a
gabi na verdade eu acho que aparece lado
porque a gente começou a colocar lembra
kassab
e até que legal eu moraria aqui ó
e puxa eu acho que você tem que é só
cuidado com isso é ver também vem um
pouco só um pouco para trás isso não
como se você tivesse de frente é ali eu
tô sentindo algo nas costas porque é
isso é o meu pinto o que é
e aí
e eu quero ir na cama ela consegue
dormir também eu quero marcar um
e a experiência está acabando com a
pouca sanidade dos nossos participantes
o que pode afetar diretamente a luta
pela sobrevivência será que serão
capazes de imitar tem um que ainda está
por vir aqui
o braga mas que [ __ ] é essa cadê a água
você me prometeu água e o seu vidro
lindo que pariu você estava aqui eu não
sei meu deus que vem cá é o sol tá indo
embora meu deus a gente tem poucas
garantias a deus é que a bolo então meu
bebê não aguentava mais não a gente
precisa encontrar sol a gente tem que
encontrar é agora lugar para ficar eu
não sei a gente não sei a gente vir logo
eu acho que tem o que inventar é como
fazer assim cara cada um tem isso é uma
foram tem não para casa a gente se
perder no meio do reserva aí a gente que
acha rapidinho e tudo ficar mais
gostosinho porque às vezes eu tenho
vontade de sair por aí sem rumo mas eu
tenho medo de perder e então precisamos
de um final e é fita porque pode ser
qualquer palavra só pode ser uma palavra
trampolim alguma coisa mais diferente
tipo sei lá que ninguém confunda como o
cu
eu perco to go on
e olha
e ai meu deus você tem correria aqui
você encontrar no água braia [ __ ]
pariu obrigada certeza realmente aí está
água no ponto de beber direto da fonte
vários água em abundância
o que maravilha água boa e corrente é
verdade é bom que ela leva as impurezas
e ela está sempre movimentada então não
tem dengue é uma boa água direto da
fonte é como se ela rejuvenescer se sabe
qualquer parte do
e aí
e olha só que eu achei que minha irmã ai
meu deus brian de palma e o [ __ ]
desgraça saber que eu encontrar algo eu
sabia que o plástico não era só para
matar que delícia levar um pouquinho
para beber mais tarde meus uma após
encontrar água é preciso alguma comida
até que nossos bravos participantes tem
algum alívio suas vidas eles estão por
um fio é em petição de miséria já mando
o papagaio de meu louro tá uma merda
mesmo com o perdão da palavra é
garantido aqui eu sabia que tinha urso
nessa [ __ ] desgraça ku ku ku
e o que aconteceu você está ficando
louco eu fui iniciar a meu deus onde
morreu cabrado avisando brian aí eu só
queria um tempo todo eu não posso mais
ficar em paz aí é perigoso medi aqui não
é legal beijar por aqui tá pegando no
meu cabelo não aguento mais isso o que
foi eu tô mijando eu já tô indo eu já tô
indo para aí agora ai filha da [ __ ] eu
não tô suportando tanto mosquito cara
ainda meu deus ai meu meu amor nada né e
aí eu estou ficando louca não não mas
não ia arrumar eu vou eu quero ir embora
daqui isso não vai resolver nada eu vou
matar ele concorrente me prometeu um
pouco
se acalma agora ele quer colocar a culpa
nos salzinho é como assim por que você
tá falando de pau de novo olha nem
sempre os relacionamentos acabam por
conta disso entende entendeu ela me
deixou porque ela se sentiu que ela
precisava de outra pessoa não importa o
tamanho aqui se dânica então olha eu
realmente não consigo entender essa sua
obtenção por tamanhos de pênis por ai ai
eu sei lá cara eu acho que vou embora
porque ela quis entendeu ela tipo fazer
isso aí não importa se o mal dele era
grande dele tá borra eu apago sim
a pessoa por favor aqui eu já estou
apagando tudo é só eu esfregar cuidar
aqui e mais um pouco aqui tá até mão
grave acertar aqui [ __ ] que pariu cama é
acho que não dá para dormir aqui aí que
eu tô morto aí pra gente que eu dormir
no relento o meu deus eu dormi mesmo do
relento sim as coisas internet dói ai
minhas costas acho que dormi em cima
desse galho dói morrer por isso
o ok sobrevivendo mas é o primeiro dia
mais do que a gente só vai fazer agora
parceiro tem comida casa não temos nada
o que você vai fazer brian para você mas
eu tô me sentindo tão fraco sabe talvez
você devesse comentou as folhas e não se
fruto sabe eu estive pensando sabe será
que a gente mira em uma direção e sai
caminhando não esse samira não vai
direção e sair caminhando o parceiro não
que eu dei uma se perder por aí porque
sabemos nós estamos eu acho isso ai meu
deus um cacto é um cacto ai meu deus não
quer isso é bom demais com certeza tem
água dentro e
o cuidado com os gatinhos como a gente
pega nisso eu não faço ideia as o vem
alguma coisa cuidado pode até cobras aí
olha só o que eu achei vou aqui se
parece com uma concha dá para pegar a
comida depois com ele leque vamos lá ó
e eu acho que a chibata tem que ser no
tronco então essa é
o e-mail essa
e olha pa olha já deu uma tunada lindo
água meu deus do céu então ontem algumas
coisas saíram de controle sabe e uma
dessas coisas foi o fogo é a que inventa
um pouco então o vento trouxe o fogo em
direção a barraca sabe e eu ainda não
tinha o meu facão para me ajudar a
apagar esse fogo entende a gente precisa
eu sair e foi assim que viemos parar
embaixo dessa árvore até que eu dormi
bem
e olha eu eu mal tenho forças preparar
sabe é tão difícil se comunicar com
brian você fala para ele cara não faz
isso mano não faz isso e ele vai lá se
achando o maioral e faz a merda
acontecer e [ __ ] que pariu isso tudo
acontece de ruim na sua vida cara eu não
aguento mais conviver com esse tipo de
pessoas e se for para onde nós morrer
por mim tanto faz eu ou ele e contando
que eu não teja mais perto dele para mim
tá valendo eu até não suporto nada não
tô apaixonada ele tem problema nem você
que dá filmando vão vai todo mundo que
[Música]
alguém me ajuda a saber o que mais tem
tutu é que isto é só consequência dele
tem queimar a tua barraca sabe eu acho
uma injustiça me deixa
o banheiro como ele poderia ter pelo
menos 15 anos é sei lá bom me corrija se
eu estiver errado mas qual é o
verdadeiro sentido deste programa em
você sabe me dizer sobrevivência é
desafios ponto abre aspas é nem sempre é
tudo são flores fechar a fazer fecha
parêntese a gente continua procurando
cara a gente tá aqui para isso a gente
veio para sobreviver é um desafio não é
a gente tem que ir até o fim no importa
o que aconteça e eu nem sei mais o que
eu tô falando eu acho que eu estou
derlando venha é eu acho que está
tranquilo a gente tá começando a vida
bem como é que você organizar e agora
ele tem até um facão então vamos lá eu
achei apesar de quem marca
e ninguém pode já tá tudo bem quem nunca
queimou uma barraca toda tentando fazer
fogo acidentes acontecem não é mesmo não
é mesmo ele é legal eu adoro a companhia
dele quem ronca não é mesmo quem não é
mesmo é
e eu vou procurar um fantasminha estamos
apresentando lascados e pelados pode vir
vamos não tenha medo hora e firme a não
deu certo eu só preciso de uma ajuda
para sair aqui não tudo isso no
cemitério então imprimi puxa não arranha
o carro isso vai caramba [ __ ] merda como
você pode ver o caso tá um pouco
avariado pela dificuldade de abrir a
porta vai sair ele é o meu xodó eu
consegui bater na bunda dele de vez em
quando tá um pouco danificado eu não sei
como isso aconteceu sem ficar meio
pedido o que foi de novo de john o outro
é como se fosse um filho sabe vai subir
estagiário esse cara só pode ter
carregado do carro minha nossa esse
carro não tem motoc eu nunca vi um carro
com dois motores ela quer saber cara eu
respeito assim cara ele tem muita
personalidade ele caga no carro eu tô
carro mais
é o verdadeiro toledo de merda nós quer
saber cara ela vai ficar uma belezura
como importante de rodas é um pouco
espaço para resolver mas a gente claro
não confio neles eles são ótimos
profissionais meu carro está em boas
mãos preta minha maravilhosa uma depois
de ver do que eles são capazes eu tenho
certeza que o carro ficará surpreendente
mas abalou minha preta mas você é
e o que achou barulho vou falar de tanta
alegria moto de novo
é uma dores de carro no muco da channel
esse é o drone da xiaomi que ele tem uma
câmera hd que me ajuda a encontrar a
serpentes muito mais rápido e de maneira
princesa eu controlo ele com o meu
celular xiaomi que é o primeiro celular
do mundo com 5 câmeras eu consigo até
tirar uma selfie é muito difícil
encontrar as cobras na selva sabe nossa
selva mas não estamos na selva nós
estamos na nossa casa e eu falei com o
meu drone aqui por aí eu preciso uma
perguntado então não é de praia por
favor muito ruim cara que saco 1
a taquinha esse cara é muito ricardo
está fazendo um
e infelizmente ele é bem uma óbito sabe
era eu ou ela pode ser uma piada seu
bobão e aí esses de um beijinho hoje
acha que isso aventuras obter simples
mas não sabem eles são muito complexos
você tem que usar coisas tecnológicas
para aquelas de borracha de borracha
para atrair da serpente de eu tenho essa
lâmpada até tchau mi mi leads marble ela
pode ser no automático pode ser
programada que eu vou ficar meio da
lâmpada elas mudam de cor sabe a gente
pode colocar aqui no na conexão esse
celular estão todos conectados olha isso
essa cobra põe o richard rasmussen que
me emprestou a ao meu deus ele não me
disse que era maligna tem como favor de
serpentes e
e voltamos a apresentar lascados e
pelados
e aí
a desgraça que aconteceu o mau dia que o
espinho não vai ter que cortar a [ __ ]
eu acho que o pior da mata é isso sabe
tudo fica enganchando em você é porque o
nosso lugar não é a mesma cuidado você
quer meu óculos ok é isso o que foi o
que é o meu deus uma caverna tem um
ninho de 2 horas viu deus macacos me
mordam olha isso eu não estou
acreditando até onde que eu não sei
talvez você tamanduá você está brincando
comigo tá morando lá na bota roupa
obrigada vamos comer como a gente faz a
gente vai beber tipo 2 filhos de
francisco a gente faz tudo bem aí
e não aparece aqui aqui mas o que é isso
parece aqui ele aparece aqui vou ver ele
tá cozido ele está custando o dedo ele
está conseguindo o meu pai está curtindo
aqui tá cozido esse esse lugar que não é
normal meu filho uma dá vontade de comer
com casca e tudo eu ainda hoje estou
naquela pele de dentro é aquela poesia
de dentro que merda né
e aí
bom então eu não vou dividir com você é
e aqui vai ser a minha poltrona e
e ai meu deus eu encontrei o meu
travesseiro e
e aqui está o grande fogo longe tá tudo
bem agora tá tudo bem ou não consigo
entender como você consegue ser tão
viciante ou você faz perto sem mais a
barraca ou faz longe demais e eu consigo
ver a luz mas faz frio aqui eu vou ter
que caminhar parece que você quer alô
brian eu fiquei correndo de cometer o
mesmo erro e um da tarde tocar fogo na
barriga de novo eu só fiquei com medo
foi isso foi isso eu não achei que eu
tivesse que expliquei aqui cavernas de
pedra não pega um pouco meu banho essa
[ __ ] né
tô de folga tu já comeu pão com
vinagrete se eu acho que sim não me
lembro sabia eu tô com fome eu queria
sei lá eu mesmo pensei frito ou assado
nessa for eu acho que eu acho que falar
não ajuda muito sabe o tem esse falam
comigo o meu deus eu tô na floresta com
alguém que fala com peixe
é um pois é meu amor é isso aí brian
deixa de bordejar e aproveita o fogo e
eu vou dormir porque a fogueira ela já
tá pagando olha aí eu não quero ficar no
relento boa noite toma cuidado que é
cheio de loucura que [ __ ] cadê meu
travesseiro e eu não tô achando meu
travesseiro o meu
e cadê meu travesseiro
bom então aqui eu vou dormir tá então
pode dormir tranquilo vigiando-a
e é muito difícil a selva esse é o meu
travesseiro hoje é tecnologia da nasa é
duro como um asteroide sabe ai pega essa
meta de câmera ai que maravilha brian
noite escolhemos de água de novo eu
achei obrigada já tô até me lembrou uma
água deus é um transparente e você já
ouviu essa música brian eu não tenho
energia para lembrar de música aqui
velho
e eu acho que tu merece ser feliz então
né eu também acho cuidado aqui é meio ar
tem pense nesse lugar eu eu não sei essa
água não me parece ser muito confiável
eu acho que achei uma coisa aqui olha eu
acho que nós o meu deus que alguma coisa
né eu achei uma linha e formas parece
que a anitta eu achei uma linha azul
para colocar muita agora só preciso de
alguém que talvez esse pau vai quebrar
não não agora não eu preciso de algo
fraco né colocaram umas ao eu posso pra
ficar sem madeira sabe eu ai meu deus
essa linha até que é boa né tu é uma
bituca de cigarro jesus o que o mundo tá
fazendo compra abrir o mundo né rita ora
meu deus eu não sei se devo tocar aqui é
meio para ela para ela abrir e se você
gosta como aquele
o time eu não acredito mas eu acho que
eu encontrei uma sol meu deus que nem eu
encontrei o sol mas nós ainda não temos
em rook é não temos aqui no whats não eu
vou ter que ir aí eu vou ter não é longe
me sacrificar por nós dois é isso que eu
tenho que fazer ai meu deus não eu tenho
que não sacrifica rodada de olho normal
mesmo eu preciso você não tá falando que
serve para verificar busão não não não
falei isso fazer por nós dois por favor
não não não não não não pára com isso
mesmo assim até por mim é com você não é
eu sou um cara que isso todo
o que é melhor para tirar também que
louco eu sou muito corajoso ai meu deus
tá latejando o meu rosto o meu uso é por
nós
[Música]
e a cuidado para não se afogar eu sei o
que eu tô fazendo aqui velho
o brian está sem medo que eu tenho a
praia olha ele está naquele rio a hora
que eu sei lá cara vai por mim eu
prefiro comer fruta nem deve ter pensa
que eu não vi nenhum animal dói ele é
e eu não aguento mais esse programa meu
deus se não der mais para mim ele
arrancou o próprio que eu estou sentindo
aqui fazendo alguma coisa mesmo problema
o mais rápido possível então eu vou lá
e eu coloquei para ninguém não
e aí
o meu deus o que foi isso como você o
que aconteceu com seu braço que ele o
meu deus eu posso falar com o seu lugar
para você quiser porque você fez isso a
minha melhor fumar um [ __ ] grata eu
tava na melhor pagar meu deus que bebê
você tá toda fudida vai cara
oi e eu nem tô falando do braço você tá
toda queimada suas costas estão queimada
aqui me aceita aí eu tô morta meu deus
espera aí um pouco aí ela nessa tem um
e nada ainda nada esse peixe não tá com
fome mas eu tô sentindo que eu vou pegar
ele depois perto eu nunca mais vai
conseguir comer mulher você é uma filha
da [ __ ] não é você é louco eu tô
e os participantes não sabiam que a
produção estava em horário de almoço
então infelizmente tem que esperar o
resgate vai dar tudo certo a produção
foi almoçar eu acabei de ouvir o
narrador falando sabe eu estou morrendo
aos poucos calma calma o doutor se
curtindo ai meu deus quero sair um
programa que não deve obrigado doutor
não tem irmão [ __ ] eu quebrei a minha
mãe apaga isso aqui eu preciso que você
fique calma não não não é muito calma
deixa eu doutor trabalhar aqui e aí
doutor calma virose uma simples virose
da para tratar como terapia é
eu estava com o braço quebrado agora eu
não estou entendendo nada meu deus que
programa é esse meu deus
e ai eu quebrei a minha mão mas o filha
da [ __ ] é tão bom aqui ele contestou e
eu vou continuar neste programa e por
uns em cima então que era de segundo eu
não sei ficar postar o meu braço eu
fiquei tão do pânico o meu deus qual é
mano [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] até o final do
programa de graça eu não sei qual é a
dela sabe que eu tô sempre buscando o
melhor para nós eu não sei parece que
ela tem mesmo ou algo contra mim sabe eu
eu tentei peça
oi tia tentei pescar por hora sabe eu
fiz o melhor que eu pude mais em vez de
ficar quieta ela foi a sei lá ela disse
que quebrou a mão andando de skate mas o
doutor disse que por pouco não atingiu o
coração vá-se danar do coco e eu tentar
sempre reclamando porque isso em você
sempre está reclamando de mim nada meu
amor é meus dentes não bebe essa água
não bebe tem gosto ai meu deus ela já
bebeu eu tô falando é a culpa disso tudo
vai ser sua contente eu já tô me
sentindo meio mal eu não queria que você
se sentisse mal também para não e outro
parceiro e deixa de falar eu hein quem
sabe se é eu beber só um pouco não faça
a diferença maria tu mas não faz mal
tudo faz mal gosto de nojo olha eu tenho
certeza que eu vi esse peixe andando
aqui
e tirando a
e o meu deus kimberlly eu achei o peixe
aqui benny hinn
o joão a
oi oi eu sou tipo esse aqui é o meu da
obra hoje vamos reformar a casa do
senhor scott ele vai ter o vigo de
felicidade quando entrar por aquela
porta
e o rita festa que já sei olha olá
amigos está em casa está tranquilo que
aprender a fazer uma receitinha vou
ficar sem internet eu vou ensinar você
aprender a fazer uma receita muito
bacana chamada só vou só vou de ontem
hahaha ele fez o pedido muito especial
ele disse só não ver seu na minha tv é
uma marca que bicho eu moro aqui há mais
de 15 anos negócio como está em seu
devido lugar por favor eu vou desligar a
tv seus deve ter tirado uma soneca é
isso aí já está aqui vamos lá galera
essa obra vamos vamos meu filho tá
fazendo o quê começa por aqui rapaz esse
cara é muito forte é muito rápido muito
camisa
e eu tomei o sangue por é só com maior
aqui ó que eu dou meu sangue meu corpo
tudo vai precisar só 10 pudesse seu
trabalho por 10 grupo né vamos lá
naquele scott esse foi hoje palmeiras e
ainda é a pena vai ter uma grande
surpresa está preparado mãos à obra a
sempre esta é um pode entrar é a pode
voar sim pode entrar e sair aqui para
mim velho boa tarde boa tarde tá bom
é uma bom vamos sim vamos sempre
acontece a roupa que é
a previsão até rural tô só esta quente
também foi o pior dia da minha vida
presta não tirei o meu diploma para isso
arrasada é uma olhada vamos embora daqui
por esta nossa senhora dos milagres
doctor já que voltamos a apresentar
lascados e pelados eu já tinha double
dessa feira mas tô isso como é meu filho
ele que eu tô carregando será que dá
para isso daí por favor e o [ __ ] eu
disse
a água não estava boa e eu tenho sentido
um negócio aqui vou ter que procurar uma
moita ele queima barraca faz da fogueira
do lado errado
e aí daqui a [ __ ] do dedo tomar no cu
parceiro ele nem me densa é carregar em
paz eu tava segurando a esse barram a um
tempão e quando eu finalmente encontra
uma mãozinha para fazer todo o processo
ele olha a praia vai ser só precisa ter
a sua água umidade da produtora né eu só
precisa de um pouco dessa que tá no seu
lado por favor de merda é
e parecem pinturas rupestres né deve ser
bem antiga essa caverna vocês haviam de
daniel nunca assisti esse filme o como
assim você nunca viu o que tem a ver eu
não preciso assistir um filme caso eu
não queira como assim você tá me
forçando a deus por aí assim que união
clássico e tem tudo a ver com a gente o
que é como assim aqui estamos no mesmo
barco navegando por terras distantes e
de repente o barco afunda porque você só
faz merda mas mesmo assim eu não deixo
você para trás como a roseli zodiac
porque eu tenho competição amor de amigo
por você você me entende só quer saber
olhando para o céu agora e olhando para
as essas escrituras eu fico pensando na
história das pessoas sabe que ele e às
vezes eu imagino se a gente escrevesse a
nossa história em vez de apagar dos
outros sabe
a merda ai meu deus cadê aqui velho
um quilo ele cu cu meu deus eu falei que
aqui tinha mula-sem-cabeça xupa cabra
essas coisas ai meu deus brian você é
muito mentiroso eu vou falar a verdade
eu fiquei com medo de ficar só aqui
vamos tirar zerinho para ver que existe
se você é uma pessoa forte eu sei tudo
bem vamos tomar uma atitude normal me
desculpa quando você dorme muitos dias
numa caverna você foi canal eu acho que
vou dar uma volta para esticar uso olha
por mais que eu tenha criado um apego
pelo brian eu tenho que falar a verdade
ele disse que foi dar uma volta mais ele
acabou dormindo e eu fiz
hoje eu vou mostrar para você faz aqui
porque na hora bater o relâmpago é muito
difícil ficar na selva ao meu deus o que
é isso meu deus ai meu deus
e é eu acho que eu tenho que
compartilhar algumas coisas que aprendi
nessa viagem sabe eu cheguei eu cheguei
muito imaturo e eu acho que eu fui
jogando os bois na frente dos bois ou é
tipo água mole em pedra dura eu não sei
é um ditado provérbio não sei mas eu eu
acho muito importante eu dizer que
aprendi muito com você aqui em berlim em
berlim desculpa te acordar mais eu tô
muito sensitiva agora isso sensível fala
meu deus a fogueira tá acabando mais eu
queria te pedir perdão
oi tudo bem eu não vou nem lutar contra
isso eu sei que eu fui um babaca idiota
mais eu quero te dizer que quando eu
sair daqui eu vou colocar em prática no
mundo real tudo que eu aprendi que às
vezes é bom a gente admitir que não sabe
as coisas
oi tudo bem você consegue me ver pega
aqui na minha mão eu o que é isso aqui
mesmo o meu deus que velho
o meu deus
o meu deus aqui ó
a fome é por você é pois é